unusually for a news conference at the
White House President Donald Trump opted
to use a teleprompter and stuck to the
script but in the week were the number
of covered 19 deaths in the u.s. went
through the 100,000 mark the president
used the occasion to cut ties with the
World Health Organization and returned
to calling it the Wuhan virus China has
total control over the World Health
Organization we have detailed the
reforms that it must make and engage
with them directly but they have refused
to act the president has been angry
about China's trade practices before he
took office the protests this week in
Hong Kong over Beijing's decision to
extend security powers there has added
to that anger Hong Kong has had a
special relationship with the US but the
president wants to punish China and says
Hong Kong special status is no more my
announcement today will affect the full
range of agreements we have with Hong
Kong from our extradition treaty to our
export controls on dual use technologies
and more with few exceptions we will be
revising the State Department's travel
advisory for Hong Kong to reflect the
increased danger of surveillance and
punishment by the Chinese state security
apparatus president also announced he
was imposing sanctions on Chinese and
Hong Kong officials I think this is the
amount of actions that he announced as
well as the severity of actions that he
did announce depending on the
implementation of these actions this is
probably the nuclear option that this
administration could have gone with do
you think China will react and respond I
think China has to respond in this case
there are so many actions that the Trump
administration announced today that if
they don't respond then domestically
they the CCP leadership risks look
looking weak to their domestic audience
President Trump gave a long list of
grievances about China's economic
actions there's nothing new there he's
done it before what was interesting in
his ten minutes in front of the cameras
he made no mention of Chinese President
gee a man he regards as strong a man
he's praised in the past
even for his handling of the corona
virus outbreak Alan Fisher al-jazeera
at the Chinese embassy in Washington